hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about something very very very important
and very interesting it's called the
coronary artery calcium score okay
first of all what is the coronary artery
well it's the main artery that supplies
blood flow to the heart and muscle so
when you have a heart attack
it's really that artery that becomes
obstructed that starves off oxygen and
blood flow to the heart muscle and it
cramps and you get a heart attack and
you die
and since heart attacks are the number
one leading cause of death worldwide it
might be a good idea to know more about
this test so you can predict if you're
gonna have a problem so if we reverse
engineer a heart attack we take it one
step back we're gonna get a cramp
okay the cramp of the heart why because
the artery is not free-flowing there's
something obstructing it
there's plaquing there could be a clot
composed of cholesterol calcium and a
certain type of protein called fibrin
and a couple other things okay so it's
all just coming in there but everyone's
so hyper focused on cholesterol they're
trying to reduce cholesterol thinking
this is what's causing this no this is
the effect of something earlier so we
put you on a statin drug and start
shutting down all the body's ability to
produce cholesterol and then we create
all sorts of other problems so the
combination between this and this is
really a band-aid coming in to heal a
lesion or a damage the wall of the
arteries so you have inflammation
because there's damage and the inside
lining of the vessel okay and the reason
why there's damage is because there's
high levels of insulin behind that so
high insulin is the culprit
I have tons and tons of videos on this
I'll put a link down below to learn more
about this but if here if you have heart
problems okay if you want to prevent
heart problems and you want to take
certain vitamins and this and that well
you also better handle this because if
this is not handled nothing is going to
work this is at the root the bottom
level cause of this chain reaction that
occurs it eventually gives someone a
heart attack
so the coronary artery calcium
test is a direct measurement of the
amount of damage in the coronary artery
okay so it gives you insights of the
person's past lifestyle of what they've
been eating what they've been doing it
predicts things a high score can occur
with normal cholesterol okay the test is
like a hundred dollars it takes two
seconds to do and you definitely need to
get it done you can have normal
cholesterol normal triglycerides normal
LDL normal blood sugars and still have a
lot of calcium in the arteries and 50%
of the time a person will die of a heart
attack without any symptoms at all so
you don't want to just be surprised so
the emphasis should not be on the
cholesterol it should be on the calcium
as the most important predictor of heart
attacks so then the question is why
aren't more medical doctors recommending
this test well there's several
viewpoints one viewpoint is why even do
the tests when we don't even know what
to do about it to actually correct it so
I'm like well that's because you're
using medical care to correct it because
you can't correct this with a drug you
can't correct this with vegetable oils
like from soy and corn you can't correct
this with healthy grains okay now if you
have a score of a thousand that means
your risk from getting a heart attack is
10x okay that's pretty high if your
score is zero your risk is extremely low
chances are you are not going to have a
heart attack you might die of getting
hit by a bus but not getting a heart
attack if your score is one to eighty
you should be concerned if your score is
81 to 400 it's a pretty serious
situation and you better start changing
your lifestyle if your score is greater
than 400 it you better make sure you
have your will completely written out
and you better start studying how to
lower this really fast but you can
reverse it you can slow it down stop it
in reverse it okay and improve it
greatly what's also interesting is that
this test can also predict risk from all
deaths not just heart attacks from
cancer from lung disease
from kidney disease so the next thing is
your doctor definitely request this test
to see where your baseline is thanks for
watching
hey if you enjoyed this video press
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated